Excellent.
Hi, I'm Badri from TokBox.
Thank you guys for
having me here.
So what I want to
talk about today--
I was originally going
to talk about building
an MCU in the cloud, but
I decided not to do that.
And I'm glad I did that,
because a whole bunch of people
before me have spoken about it.
But what I'd like to do today
is really talk about WebRTC
and a whole bunch of
interesting applications
which are being built
on top of WebRTC.
I was talking to [? Serge ?]
from Google last week,
and he was describing
these use cases
and he was telling me about
how the magic of WebRTC
is really in the moments.
It's all of these
little scenarios,
real-time communication
on the web enabled.
So what I'd like to do
today is basically just
talk about a whole slew of
interesting applications
which has been
enabled by WebRTC,
and give you guys
a flavor of what
is happening in the
ecosystem out there.
So far warning, I just picked
at random set of use cases.
So please don't be offended
if your application or use
case doesn't
prominently show up.
Jumping along,
what I wanted to do
is pick a full spectrum of
very interesting use cases
and say, OK, these are the sorts
of interesting applications
which are to being
built by WebRTC.
And WebRTC is just
the technology.
And what makes it
really interesting
is all of these very
rich experiences
which are being built.
And the first
example I have here
is this mobile application
which is called Valspar.
And what Valspar
essentially does
is-- it's sort of a
service application
when you're painting your walls
of your home or what have you.
You can actually schedule
a real-time appointment
with a consultant.
And then you can go and actually
have that wall or that area
you're painting be viewed
by the consultant, who
gives you real-time advice.
And like Chris and [? Saheed ?]
mentioned, all of the code
is open source.
So you can easily
think about sort
of compiling it into
your own platform
and doing really interesting
things with the application
itself.
In the case of a mobile
device, you can easily
think of intercepting the
media stream from the camera,
or before it's being
rendered on the screen, how
you can overlay the
right color combination.
Let's say, if you wanted to know
what your walls look like when
it was painted
yellow, go for it.
The remote consultant
can actually do that.
So this is a very
interesting use case
which is being enabled by real
time communication on the web,
and WebRTC specifically.
Jumping on.
I'm going to be showing a
whole slew of use cases.
And I love developers that
have pet projects and hacks.
Apologies for this slide,
cause it doesn't show properly
over here.
But what this is-- this is a
webcam controlled HTML5 slide
operator by Luigi.
And what it is, it basically
uses the getUserMedia API,
and you can use gestures to
enable the slide transitions.
So instead of using a clicker
or instead of using something
like that, you could
essentially wave and actually
make these transitions happen.
Again, this is
not very apparent.
A lot of people
think about WebRTC
as being audio and video,
but that's only one half
of the equation.
One half of the equation is
to do what your phone already
does on the web.
But clearly, the other
half of the equation
is all of these very interesting
use cases and applications,
some of which we
don't know as yet,
which are going to be
enabled by this technology
by developers all over the map.
So this is a very simple
but very interesting
use case, which is sort of both.
Yesterday we had a whole bunch
of fun, bobbing around at work,
trying to make this
slide transition.
We thought we'd try and actually
use this for my talk today,
but you know.
I couldn't get
my-- I was not that
articulate in terms of gestures.
I couldn't make that happen.
Again one of the big things
WebRTC enables-- and we
see this all the time-- is
redefining communication.
All the time, we
communications as being
sort of a [? siloed ?]
application.
If I want to call somebody,
I pick up my telephone.
If I want to send a
message to somebody,
I use Google Chat or
WhatsApp or what have you.
But what WebRTC
essentially has enabled
is moved communications out of
a standalone concept in context.
So, I need to be able
to communicate and use
something around an
existing context,
and not think of communications
as a standalone experience.
Ustyme is a very
interesting example
of an application out there.
Again, it's a
mobile application.
And what they have
done is try and engage
or create very more
real-time communication
experiences centered
around content.
Imagine a grandparent
trying to talk
to his or her grandchildren
using a pure video conference.
That's not very engaging
to the children.
So what they have
done is, they say,
we can build all
these experience
is centered around a content.
This could be around a game.
This could be around a book--
somebody who is travelling can
actually read a bedtime
story to their child,
and the child picks up an iPad.
And we see all of these
very interesting, sort
of visceral experiences when
people use these applications.
So again this is
a very interesting
content-centered
sort of use case.
This is an example I wanted
to talk about, again,
just to emphasize the fact that
WebRTC is not about pure audio
and video.
Although there are a lot of
whole bunch of interesting use
cases, there are an
equal, if not greater,
number of use cases that people
are using interesting features
in WebRTC to accomplish
interesting things.
Here's an example of Pipe.
Pipe is this service which
enables people to share files.
And if you were
my Facebook friend
and I was your
Facebook friend, then
we would be able to share
content and very large
files across from each other.
This was essentially enabled
by the data channels feature
within WebRTC.
So if you remember Chris'
slide from the morning,
WebRTC is more than
just audio and video.
It's about other forms of data.
People have been working on
very interesting projects
with the data channel
especially, creating
annoymized file transfer or
creating content delivery
networks and using the
peer-to-peer mechanism
to speedup content
delivery networks.
I see the guys from
[? Clear CDN. ?] So there's
a lot of interesting
applications out there, which
are not so much center
around audio and video,
but are sort of
radical in how WebRTC
has enabled them to happen.
Moving on.
Again, this is a
very interesting
developer-center project.
This is basically an AR Drone.
It's the Parrot.
It's essentially a quadcopter,
which has got a front-facing HD
camera and a
down-facing HD camera.
And Rohit, the
developer, basically
built a very simple
web-based interface
to be able to control
this quadcopter.
Again, he used some
elements WebRTC to do that.
And it's a fun exercise,
all these things
people playing around with.
We essentially want to get
a couple of these at work.
And one of my pet
projects has been
to have quadcopter
battles, but it's
a pretty low priority on
the list at this point.
So again, very
interesting use case
of all sorts of things
that WebRTC enables.
Again, there's a
whole host of interest
which is happening in sort of
vertical-centric use cases.
Like medical devices
and medical technology
is an interesting
area where there's
a lot of things which have
been enabled by WebRTC.
This is an app by a company
called Net Medical Express.
And what they do is they make
medical device trolleys which
you can wheel to a
developing-- it's
used in Brazil or any sort
of developing country--
and it essentially
enables you to communicate
to the doctor or the technician
using audio and video.
And an interesting
extension to a use case
such as this that you
can easily imagine
is playing it out on
the different sorts
of input devices.
We see interesting use cases
where people are playing around
with things like microscopes,
and intelligence telescopes,
and sort of sensors to actually
pipe data using WebRTC data
channels, and build a very
immersive experience where
you can alternate
between audio and video
and also what the
input device provides.
For instance, if I'm
talking to a doctor,
it can potentially alternate
between talking to the doctor,
as well as seeing
an X-ray directly
from an X-ray machine
or something like that.
So again, WebRTC has
enabled a whole bunch
of very interesting
applications which
have sort of gained
traction in this area.
This is, again, a little fun.
I'm alternating, sort of serious
apps and then the fun apps.
The Guitar Tuner-- there
are a bunch of guitar tuners
which were
implemented in WebRTC,
and it's a whole bunch of fun.
Yesterday, somebody at
work was very curious,
as I was playing
around with this app,
as to why Lauren
and I are making
high-pitched noises
in the corner.
We were actually trying
this out to see if it works.
And apparently Lauren can hold
the tune better than I can.
But again, this is a very
interesting application,
completely sort of
out of the box when
you think about what
WebRTC has enabled.
I might have-- there we go.
Again, we truly
believe that there's
a lot of interesting opportunity
in the services industry,
as well as the
internet of things.
For those of you
who know Fluke, they
make multimeters and sort of
electrical devices and systems
like that.
They are sort of
working on a thing which
is called Fluke Connect, which
essentially collaborates,
or puts in touch, people in
sort of a services routine.
And basically the
way it works is,
if I were a junior
apprentice and I'm actually
going and fixing an
electrical issue or whatever,
and I'm not really
sure how to fix it,
what it enables
you to do is-- It's
a See What I See use case, where
I can point to the fried wiring
circuit and call
the expert engineer,
and he can actually
see what's going on
and sort of help
debug that issue.
And if you think about
this very simple See What
I See model, which
WebRTC has enabled,
it's essentially applicable
to most services.
Most services--
whether it's plumbing,
whether it's real estate
assessments, whether it's
color consultants
for painting-- I
think it's basically
opened up a whole raft
of interesting opportunities
in the service industry.
And an interesting
extension to that,
again, is you can think about
different-- with the internet
of things-- you can
actually think about all
these other devices'
sensors actually
encoding data into
this application
while the real-time
conversation is happening.
So again, this is
sort of a cool use
case, which is being
enabled by WebRTC.
And one of the
points I want to make
as we're walking through
all of these here,
is there's a lot of conversation
that generally happens
about some of these are
supported by the standards,
as it exists today.
A lot of things are not
supported by the standards.
But essentially,
because of the fact
that WebRTC is an open
standard and protocol
and all of the
source code is open,
it actually opens
up a whole host
of options or
opportunities for people
to actually go beyond what
merely the standard exists
today.
There is no reason why somebody
cannot take the source code
and sort of tweak it
very interesting ways--
use the service provider, use
an open source software stack,
what have you.
Again, there's a lot of
online tutoring education
sort of scenarios which
WebRTC apps are being built.
But I thought this would be
another interesting application
from that end.
It's called Capiche.
And what they want to do
is be able to crowd source
or connect live
interpreters with people
who want interpretation
services.
If I were at an important
business meeting
or what have you, and I wanted
interpretation services,
I can actually use this app,
and actually set up this call
and get access to a live
pool of interpreters.
Again, this is a very simple,
yet interesting use case
which WebRTC has opened up.
This is one of my
favorite examples.
It's not just about service
industries and things
like that.
This is called rapt.fm
and what they do
is they hosted live rap battles.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm not kidding
you, this exists.
And it's quite amazing.
You can actually go there.
You can watch all these people
sort of battle each other
and there is live
voting and all of that.
It's quite remarkable the sort
of creative applications which
are being built,
centered around WebRTC.
[INAUDIBLE]
I wish.
And sort of coming towards
the end of my presentation,
but here is a very
interesting application.
Again, it's sort of a
See What I See use case.
But the point I
want to make here
is it also extends
to all other areas
where that scenario make sense.
In this case, Be
My Eyes is actually
based out of a
nonprofit in Denmark.
It was started by a
visually-impaired person.
Where oftentimes you have
a lot of trouble reading,
like, nutrition labels and
different things like that.
They're still not accessible
to majority of people.
And what they are building-- or
they're using WebRTC to build--
is to build this
See What I See app which
puts visually-impaired people
in touch with a
pool of volunteers.
So, if I wanted to volunteer
three hours of my time,
I could essentially register
and a person on the other end
could flip on the phone,
put a request for my help.
And then I can tell them,
or I can describe to them
what exactly I'm seeing.
So if you look at it
from that context,
from a technology
point of view, it's
a very simple app to build.
But in terms of
the social impact
it can have, in
terms of the good it
can do, it's quite remarkable,
all of these use cases.
And again, all of these
have been enabled by WebRTC.
It's not that-- these were
possible to do in the past,
but were very harder.
Today, a web
developer can go look
at the online tutorials,
the source code,
and quickly write a
couple lines of JavaScript
and actually have a live
video conference running.
And finally-- The final
example is a whole bunch
of robotics companies are
also embracing WebRTC.
This is a company
called Double Robotics.
What they do is they build
a telepresence robot, which
is sort of a gyroscopically
controlled robot.
You stick an iPad into
the head of the robot.
It looks like Short Circuit V2.
And you can remotely
control this robot
and drive it around
from either a mobile app
or from your browser,
from Chrome or Firefox.
And it's quite possible to
have this robot go around
and be part of remote
meetings and stuff like that.
You can actually wheel
yourself into a conference.
The screen can slide up and
down so you can actually
see what's on the screen.
There's also a
prism which enables
you to see what's
underneath the robot,
so that it doesn't trip and fall
over wires, or what have you.
So, it's, again, a very
interesting use case
which is being enabled
purely by advent of WebRTC.
So that's the end
of my presentation,
but what I'd like to
leave all of you with
is hopefully a slice of
all of the applications
which are being built and WebRTC
is essentially the technology.
And truly for the
technology to be valuable
it depends upon everybody
in this room and everybody
beyond to build all
these rich, immersive,
fun experiences, which actually
touch people's lives in a very
tangible manner.
So I encourage all of you
guys to actually use WebRTC.
Play around.
It's very simple.
And come up with
interesting applications.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]